Hello, hello, hello, hello.
Welcome to Devil May Cry 5.
Five.
We're here.
Devil May Cry 5.
We've been through... What?
Through four?
Including two?
We've been through the whole journey.
Whoa.
Casey.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you for the HakuSupa.
What?
No spoilers, but there are a few things that your Metal Gear brain will latch onto.
Now I'm motivated.
That's so funny.
I almost asked.
I was almost going to be like...
Hey guys, should I buy any of the DLC?
There's like DLC on Steam for this game.
Wait, hold on.
Let me see.
View all in store.
Like there's bananas.
I kinda want that.
I kinda want the bananas.
Maybe I shouldn't look at this though.
I like how you can still buy Rorbs and Blorbs though.
That's pretty funny.
Maybe make you never cry.
Thanks, Golden Foxy!
Thank you.
You can get it later.
Yeah, I think we'll... I think we'll... Maybe a second... Next... Next time I play.
Hope you enjoy DMC5.
It will be peak.
Love you.
Thank you, Leto!
Thank you.
Minto tags.
There is no such thing.
DMC3 has lots of very cool cutscene live action and behind the scene motion capture content.
Ooh, I like... I actually really like motion capture content.
It's something I've always wanted to do is like be a... Motion capture... Actor?
So that part of... Stuff really interests me.
So thank you!
Oh, did you guys watch W3?
Did you guys watch... Here.
Actually, I'm gonna link it.
One second.
Yes?
It's a little different from the first two.
I hope you guys don't mind... Hold on.
I don't want it to play though.
Wait.
Shut up.
There we go.
Okay.
Watch...
Wait.
Wait Zinko says, I'm so sorry.
Good vibes today.
Good vibes, good vibes, good vibes.
Good vibes.
Yeah, let me also say... No spoilers, because this is my first time playing.
And... If you're here for good gameplay, don't watch VTubers.
Or like 90% of VTubers.
Yeah.
Oh, that's my... That's my opening statement.
I'm here for cute ghostmates.
If you want... If you want silly...
Then you're in the right place, maybe.
I was talking with a friend earlier.
And I was just like, you know...
Obviously, there's one thing to really watch someone be good at a game.
Like some people who are like...
Able to play games blindfolded.
But then at the same time...
You know, you don't...
I mean...
If someone's... It depends.
It depends on how someone plays their game.
Like...
I... Sorry.
I talk about Big Saru all the time.
Because I'm obsessed with his channel.
But he's...
Uh...
He's a...
A Metal Gear...
Player.
I was not wed to you.
But...
He also is so good at the game that he...
Like messes around a lot and does silly things.
So there's like people that are really good at games and are able...
Are so good that they can do silly things and get away with it.
But then there's also like...
People that are taking games so seriously.
They're so serious.
They're so...
They're so serious about how people play.
Spoilers.
Everyone is hot.
Thank you guys for the super time.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Come for the silly.
Stay for the freaky.
Woo!
Oh yeah.
So...
But I like...
You know...
Even if I'm not...
Good at the game.
I can at least...
You can maybe get a chuckle out of...
Out of some of the gameplay.
So...
The...
What I'm trying to say is...
Don't take things so seriously.
That's me being the...
Joker.
Why so serious?
Will you watch the recap?
There's a recap?
Is it the history of DMC?
Is that like...
Because last time it was a bunch of text.
In the...
In DMC4.
So...
And I couldn't keep up reading it.
I was like...
I was a rap god.
It's a video this time.
Watch a movie that explains the history.
Yes.
I would love to watch this.
Thank you guys for all the...
Donuts.
We're for a drinker.
Welcome to DMC5.
Congrats on making it at this point.
Thank you.
All the moves, fights, stingers, blurbs, uphills, downhills.
I've led you to this point.
Hope you enjoy this crazy game.
Yeah!
I'm so excited.
People have always been like...
Um...
Have always been like...
Five is...
Five is where it's...
All...
Cumulates.
It's all...
It's all leads up to five.
Which I mean...
That's how games...
That's how series work.
But also...
That five is like the best.
Medium difficulty is always the intended experience by the devs.
F the haters.
Ah!
I didn't pick human.
I picked Devil Hunter.
That's the same as four.
So...
That's what I did last time.
Mm-hmm-hmm.
First time live, viewer!
Woo!
Thank you!
And thank you for the super chat.
I really appreciate it.
He said he made this for the fans.
That he was confident it will exceed all expectations.
Whoa!
Okay.
I'm going in with big expectations!
I'm going in with big expectations.
But before we start, let's watch the movie.
To get a little bit of a recap.
Happy.
Long ago.
A single demon challenged the Emperor of the Underworld for the sake of mankind.
The demon would prove victorious and seal off the Underworld.
Dark Knight.
Oh my gosh, and I'm the Joker.
That demon was the Dark Knight Sparta!
Yeah, that guy.
Sparta's legend spread, and the legendary Dark Knight was revered by mankind.
But as the years slipped by, the memory of his deeds and the existence of demons faded from memory.
After 2,000 years, the seal on the Underworld began to weaken.
The demon Emperor Mundus sent his minions after Sparta's wife and twin sons...
Oh, in an act of something.
Sorry.
Sparta's human wife, Eva...
No chance against the demons and lost her life.
One of Sparta's sons, Virgil, went missing.
The only survivor was Dante.
Virgil's twin brother.
Decades later.
Oh.
Dante was reunited with his lost brother, Virgil.
Virgil survived.
Oh, sorry.
I was supposed to be read.
He got Yamato.
Arkham, a man bent on obtaining demonic power, knew that unlocking Sparta's power would weaken the seal on the Underworld!
To this end, Arkham manipulated Virgil from the shadows to fulfill his saluted ambitions.
Conflicted over his feelings for his lost brother, Dante set out to stop Virgil and Arkham.
Along the way, Dante met a demon under the name of the lady!
Her lust for revenge!
You can't say lust for revenge.
Woo!
Sorry.
The battle between brothers was fierce, but Virgil met his match.
In the end, he refused Dante's help as he fell alone into the Underworld.
Soon after, Dante opened his shop for business.
Devil may cry!
Frunting as a local handyman, he used his business to hunt down demons and collect information on...
Was it Mundus?
Is that what he said?
Sometime later, a mysterious and beautiful woman appeared at Dante's door.
The woman's name was Trish, and she bore a striking resemblance to Dante's deceased mother!
Now we're on Devil May Cry.
She led Dante to Mallet Island, where Mundus had been sealed away.
Away!
There, Dante faced a gauntlet of Mundus' minions, all of whom who fell the...
Oh, sorry.
One such adversary was revealed to be Virgil, warped into the demon known as Nilo Angelo!
In the face of Mundus' cruelty, Dante's anger erupted like never before!
The true power Dante inherited from his father Sparta was unleashed, which he used to seal Mundus away once again!
Why?
Wait!
Is this the anime?
Many demons continued to invade the human world.
But not even demonic rulers rivaling the power of Mundus could match Dante.
Always at peace in the human world.
Yeah, the original, right?
But not for long!
Devil May Cry 4!
A Sparta worshipping cult known as the Order of the Sword.
Oh, it's so bad.
Those Dante trolls...
Thank you, Sparta!
Oh, wow.
So...
What is this remix?
You came to die!
Wait, this is so good!
Nero learned of the Order's true goals during his pursuit of Dante and was killed...
Wait, oh, sorry.
Unbeknownst to all, Virgil's sword Yamato has been in the Order's possession.
The blade resonated with Nero, arriving here with new demonic powers!
This is proof enough that the blood of Sparta coursed through Nero's veins as well.
Having learned of the Order's sinister plans, Nero confronted...
A fellow Holy Knight and Mentor credit card with his involvement.
But alas, his former mentor had been working towards the Order's goals all along!
On top of everything, Sanctus was revived with the aid of nefarious powers.
Nero's beloved Chidiae was taken hostage!
My sister, wife, and the lovers were absorbed into the core of the Order's ultimate weapon.
The savior!
Enraged over his sister, Chidiae's treatment, Credo tried to save Nero, only to be dealt a fatal blow at the hand of Sanctus!
Not the rule!
And we were all satisfied.
Nero was then able to defeat Sanctus and put an end to the Order's evil...
Uh, something... something's happened.
Dante sensed in Nero the same connection to Sparta's power, and so entrusted Yamato to the youth before leaving Fortuna.
The two parted ways and continued their fight against demons in defense of the human world.
The two descendants of Sparta kept the world safe, and at peace for many years.
But nothing lasts forever.
And a crisis looms on the horizon, the likes of which their world has never seen.
And they just...
They just completely be like...
Two?
Uh, never heard of her.
Yay!
Oh, yeah!
One...
Three, four!
And they showed more of...
Of the anime than they did of two.
The real question is, are you going to watch the live-action cutscenes at the DLC?
Uh, maybe.
I want to play the game first, though.
Thanks for the nice read-through.
I did my best.
Fronting is a handyman.
He should've...
More like Fronting-ass Pizza Man.
That guy didn't...
That guy doesn't...
Probably has never held a wrench before.
It's like, you guys...
You say...
You're like, hey, Dante, can you give me the Allen wrench?
And he's like, Allen who?
I don't know that guy.
Two got the portable ops treatment.
Wow!
Good...
Good, uh, recap of everything.
And now...
We're on to...
Five!
The...
Quote-unquote final game.
Um, I have lots of people asking if I will play...
Like, DMC, Devil May Cry.
Um, just so that I don't keep...
Resp...
Uh, uh...
Answering the question over and over again.
I'm still deciding.
I don't know yet if I will or not.
Just because...
Um...
I don't know yet.
So...
Yeah.
That's just...
I don't know yet.
That's all.
Anyway.
Oh my god.
Obviously, I guess...
V.
Interesting.
Fun.
There's three characters now!
Oh.
There was...
At once a demon who saved the human world from destruction...
I can't read anything in this game.
And it grew both day and night...
Till it bore an apple bride.
V has come too!
Whoa!
That was really triggering my trepophobia.
This thing's nasty.
Big ol' pomegranate.
I'm that guy with his hand on his hips.
He's like...
Well, that's peculiar.
Whoa!
Oh, I forgot to say too, you guys.
May 16th!
It's almost that day!
Oh my gosh!
Wait, why didn't you guys tell me this took place on May 16th?
I would have started it then.
We've known each other a long time.
Uh-oh.
There's no subtitles.
You never had this much trouble.
Senpai, happy birthday!
You're gonna make it through this, Dante.
Ah!
Dante!
He's so old!
Jack Frost!
What am I doing, wasting my time here?
He's got this!
Oh, he's got a haircut!
Vero!
You should not underestimate this demon.
Mysterious!
After all, it was he who took your right arm.
And gained a great deal of power from it.
I'm leaving.
I suggest you do not fall behind.
Not to...
What the hell?
Okay, Fae.
You're an interesting guy, but you're right.
He's just skating away.
I'm a freak.
I've got a score to settle with that son of a bitch.
We're like so media ray.
Oh my god.
Whoa.
Oh, wow.
Wait, is there a way I can turn on subtitles?
Oh, my arm!
Wait, Nira, what happened to you?
What a...
So much has...
So much has happened.
Hold on.
Okay.
Wait, let me go to options first and turn on...
I'm guessing it's under language.
Subtitles.
Yes.
Thank you.
Okay.
Wait, I also saw that there was Japanese, but it actually won't let me change it.
It's just kind of interesting.
I'm not left-handed.
Oh, look, there's like a whole melee attack, gun attack.
Okay, it's all unused.
Why is B unused?
Unused.
Jump.
Change.
Lock on.
Unused?
The D-pad's unused?
For now.
Maybe.
Lock on.
Yo.
Whoa!
Jeff, thank you so much for the...
Oh, thank you.
Also, I'm sorry.
Let me sing happy birthday before we...
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to Simbad.
Happy birthday!
Oh, my gosh.
We're just so in the middle of this right now.
Okay.
Exceed.
Taunt.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Are those my Blorbs and my Rorbs?
The Rorbs look hideous.
Okay.
Kai?
Dante.
Oh!
Oh, there's...
Some people said he looks like Kylo Ren.
I see it, though.
Yeah?
Oh!
It's a...
Jump.
Okay.
All right.
I'm keeping up.
Oh!
Where the...
I'm not keeping up.
Just kidding.
I lied.
Oh, raspberry!
Oh!
Em...
Pew shot!
When a barrier blocks off your path...
Yep, yep.
I know that.
The seals...
I can take you with no arms.
Ho-ho!
Wait.
Nice.
I have, like, no...
Oh!
Oh, it's so ugly!
A lot of references to DMC Devil May Cry in file.
Oh, well...
That's okay.
Oh, there's more!
Okay.
Oh.
Wait.
What did it say?
Oh, change lock-on.
That's...
Yeah, I know.
Yeah, that's okay.
Oh, it's so stylized.
The game is loud?
I'll turn it down.
It's so stylized!
Everything is...
Wow!
Wow-wee!
Oh, this way.
I guess...
I trust you.
I thought the audio was fine.
I can turn it up just a little bit.
I'll put it in between, but I just had it.
These things are so nasty!
Everything's so HD and so good-looking.
Ah!
Eww!
Oh, my God!
High roller.
You have a number of special moves.
Okay, yeah.
Hold down Y to follow them into the air.
Neat.
Hold X until you're...
Oh...
Oh, okay, okay.
We have that.
Okay.
Color up.
Ravens helping each other out.
What's the world coming to?
Hi-ya-yah-yah.
Young-yah.
Wait, hold on.
Out of the way!
Oh, wait.
Oh, I forgot to hold Y.
There we go.
Yeah, badass!
Oh!
Eww!
Everything looks so gross!
Oh, come on, come on, come on, come on!
I just barely missed him.
Come here!
Oh yeah.
Oh yeah, hold on.
Hold X.
I'm holding.
Is that it?
Oh!
RE Engine for TMZ5.
Nerissa's in this game.
Come on with your bad self.
Okay.
Whoa.
Oh, oh, sorry, sorry.
What the hell?
I was just looking around.
I didn't think that we would get a full shot of...
Oh!
Come here!
Oops, I meant up.
Come here, come here.
Dismal.
Oh, villain!
Oh my gosh!
What's up with all the Argo Superbuzz?
I wasn't able to beat all five games.
That's okay, why would you apologize?
But thank you!
Managed to beat DMZ3 with Royal Guard only in honor of your Royal Guardless DMZ.
All right, although the final boss took me almost an hour.
Oh my gosh!
Yeah, your motivation.
Do these have things?
Come here.
Whoa...
Starring the DMZ crew.
Where's your motivation?
Nope, nevermind.
It's kinda weird that you, like, absorb the Rorbs immediately.
I like destroying these.
More nasally?
Oh, sorry.
Nasty!
I don't think I'm getting anything from these, but it's still fun.
I don't know.
This guy's so cool!
He looks like, almost like he could be a Dark Souls boss or something.
Also, I'm so stupid.
Like, I've been watching Nimi play, uh...
Elden Ring?
Elden Ring.
And I was just like...
I was like, wow.
This game...
Feels like Dark Souls.
And because of my brain, I...
I could...
I replaced Elden Ring with Elder Scrolls.
And so, I was just like, is she...
Is she playing, like, Skyrim?
I was like, I thought Skyrim was different than this.
It's so weird.
I was like, huh?
This looks so hard.
People told me to play Skyrim.
I...
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna die all the time.
So, I was like...
This whole time, she's been playing it for, like, weeks.
And my dumb ass has been like, why is it like Dark Souls?
I thought it was an adventure game.
The reason Virgil is so nasally is because he had a cold.
I think that was a myth though, no?
And Elden Scrolls.
Has an online feature.
I did see that.
Um...
I did see that because it asked me at the beginning of the game.
It was just like...
There's a photo mode!
Hold on, sorry.
It asked me at the beginning of the game.
It was like, do you...
I'm sorry, I'm not gonna be this obnoxious with pausing usually, but...
It asked me if I wanted to, um...
Uh...
Like, play with friends or not.
Smile, Nero!
He's got his little...
Oh, sorry.
Oh.
I saw...
I definitely saw his skull.
Wow, buddy.
We need to get you on some sort of skin care routine.
Like, pronto.
Holy!
I saw his teeth.
Yeah.
He's got teeth.
Oof.
It's okay.
He still...
He looks like old Jack Frost.
Okay.
Moisturize!
He's like, I'm too busy fighting demons.
Wait, what's up right this way?
A lot of nothing.
RE engine?
But yeah, but like...
But like...
Leon is...
He's like...
Fishy boy.
Lady!
Oh my god!
Trish!
Everybody's down!
Dang!
Uh-oh.
Looks like this won't be a total waste of time after all.
Hey!
Jackass!
Didn't your mother ever teach you it's not nice to steal?
Wait, I'm supposed to fight something that...
Sorry Dante!
Took out our whole team?
I'm bagging this bitch!
Yeah!
Oh no!
Yeah, I totally...
Know how to do that.
Oh yeah, I totally know how
to...
Oh!
I jumped right into it.
I tried to jump away from it.
Ah!
Wait, can I still dot?
Oh yeah, I can.
Okay.
Oh!
Wait!
No!
Oh,
I missed the boat!
Oh my god!
He's actually hard!
Oh, come on!
Is
this one of those fights you're not actually supposed to win?
Because um...
Why?
You barely hit an empty...
Oh god!
You can win?
No way.
Oh, oops.
See guys, it's all according to plan.
You can actually beat it, that's crazy.
This is it!
This is the end!
It's all over!
Help us, Kylo Ren!
Use the force!
Oh my god.
Nero got beat in like two seconds.
Dante?
Oh my god.
This is so old.
How much time took place after...
Four?
Round two.
Oh my god.
Elderly Ren!
No!
Damn!
Oh!
Dead weight!
You must leave here!
You are stronger than we ever could have imagined!
Oh!
Noooo!
Frosted call me Deadweight!
But he come all this way for the other!
Oh, you're gonna lose your other arm, Nero!
There's Alan.
Dante won't lose.
Oh my god.
Look at that!
Oh wait.
Uh oh!
This is bad.
Sorry.
I was looking at the wrong thing.
No!
Rebellion!
Someone defeat Groot right now!
No!
Wait, he's still alive, though.
It's fine.
Ew!
What?
Me too!
It doesn't look good.
Oh no!
Why were you all standing so close?
Dante lost?
Dante!
Just casually walking away.
What?
See?
It's so dramatic.
Oh.
No!
Oh, we're on June now.
Being part demon is the dry skin and massive pores.
Yeah.
See for clap.
Ah!
Uh-oh.
We had, like...
A whole month...
To get better.
Niko niko n...
One month later.
There's so many new characters now.
They've expanded business like crazy.
One month ago.
In light of this incident.
The government...
This is a trial from the heavens above.
Same crap, different day.
So, tell me.
Tell you what?
How does it feel to be rescuing the guy that killed your father?
Hey, I'm glad we're getting personal.
Well, he abandoned my mother and I and left us for dead.
So, I feel nothing.
Well, he's not exactly going up for father of the year ward now, is he?
Hmm...
His research wasn't that bad.
Came in handy.
Mowbley, thank you for that.
I have to do that in here.
It already smells like gas.
That's you.
Oh, nasty.
Hey, Niko.
Don't lose your tits.
I'll see you.
Wow, the branded truck.
It's so good.
Hey, you have to hit every single bump in the road.
She's just taking out a few.
This is how you play any sort of, like, GTA game.
Oh my god!
Ow!
The credits!
Yeah!
I'm doing all this, by the way.
Oh my god, I just noticed his robot part.
It's not...
There's no arm attached, but...
Oh yeah!
Wait!
I just realized with Sire!
Bang!
Pull my devil trigger!
Oh
my god!
Oh my god!
Oh!
Nice!
Nice.
This game does not promote smoking.
Thank you.
Thank you, game.
Oh, look at the five on the truck.
That's so cute.
Devil May Cry 5.
No, Nero doesn't like smoking.
He said it was stinky.
Oh.
You got this.
June 15th, 5am.
Yeah, be like Nero.
Oh my god.
The bus is here.
Your Uber driver is here.
You look like you need a hug.
But you're not going to get one from me.
You better get lost.
Hey, who are you?
Hey, you're going to get yourself killed.
Don't crap yourself.
He likes to kill demon things.
Let him do his thing.
I like her country action.
You know what I said?
You don't want I'm son of a bitch.
You're going to die.
He's like, just watch it.
Whoa!
Wait a second.
Is that our grabby grab?
All right.
Time to kick some ass.
Never notice the five on the truck?
Wait, is that our grabby grab?
Press B to perform your devil breaker special attack.
Taking damage while executing this attack will destroy your current devil breaker.
Hold B then release.
Verging an attack will make that attack more powerful.
But the devil breaker you have equipped will be destroyed.
I've got some cleaning up to do.
This guy's okay, right?
Wait, so...
Two at once.
I can't.
I'm too good at this game.
Oh my
god.
This guy is having...
He's having like an epiphany.
A life-changing moment.
To kick demon ass.
Oh, no.
Hey, psycho!
Watch the merchandise.
Hey, stop bitchin' and take cover.
This is...
It's a little...
It's fine.
How does it do that though?
How many are in there?
Wire snatch.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Enhanced grabby grab.
Pulling enemies you've locked onto.
Heavy enemies can't be pulled in.
So use this technique to pull closer instead.
Break away.
I'll be...
You can forcefully have severed your devil breaker.
To generate an explosion.
You can use this to get out of dangerous situations.
What?
Wait.
Come here.
Yeah.
Wait.
Oh.
My bad.
Stop drop and roll.
Wait.
LB.
Ow.
Neat.
I'm really getting the hang of this new toy.
Shut up.
Getting used to it.
Oh.
Someone read it.
Thank you.
Overture.
Picking up devil breakers.
Touch a devil breaker.
Walk over any devil breaker you find to pick it up.
And equip it automatically.
You cannot pick up any new arms if your magazine is already full.
Do I have...
Do I have ammo in this game?
They're disposable.
They're consumables?
You have arms.
Arm ammo.
No.
No way.
My devil may cry would never...
Wait.
There's another one.
Oh.
Okay.
Thanks.
She just left it on the ground for us.
That doesn't seem good.
Wait.
What did I just do?
What did I just grab?
Where did I get these from?
Where are the rorbs coming from though?
I don't...
Wait.
Am I supposed to kill these?
No.
Oh.
I just noticed they're like human faces.
They're even worse than I first thought.
I don't see where the rorbs are.
Where...
Oh, there...
There's...
Oh.
I see him now.
Aha.
I see.
I see him now.
I need...
I need air hike, like...
Pronto.
Whee.
Where is he?
Where did that guy go?
Hello?
Oh.
Whoa.
What is that?
Oh.
There's more.
Crazy.
Oh, there's another one.
Okay.
Oh.
Bye.
Oh my god.
Hold down, V.
I'm holding, I'm holding, I'm holding, I'm holding.
Hey.
Chill out.
Okay.
So that, there's like a charge attack.
I guess I killed that guy in the explosion.
I didn't even realize.
Oops.
What a lovely house plant.
All the fo...
Faults.
Roots.
You missed the blor...
There was a blorb!
I'm still getting used to the intense...
I brought the marshmallows.
I'm revving, but it's like not working.
Dodging.
Yeah, I did that.
Okay.
Am I revving?
Oh.
Swing in a minute.
Okay.
Whoop.
It's shining.
Yeah.
Oh.
Ouch.
Two.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
Dang, they hit hard.
Wait.
Oh.
Let me, let me rev up.
That didn't do nearly as much as I thought it would do.
Okay, never mind.
I just...
Woo, woo, woo, woo, woo, woo.
Oh, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I feel slower in this game.
I don't know why.
Ouch.
Am I slower?
Or is it just...
Arm
that blew up.
Ah.
Oh.
It's a little slower.
The camera's further out, I think.
Maybe that's it.
My depth perception.
We'll get faster with upgrades.
Hey.
Tough guy.
That'll keep up, but not for long.
What do you mean?
Soldier boy said city's gone to hell and back.
Taken over by the underworld.
Uh-oh.
Not just here, but everywhere.
Why don't you know the game and secrets on our first playthrough?
I know.
Yamato did this.
April 3rd.
Do you know what day it is tomorrow?
Why do I feel like your pet mechanic?
We're so close to the actual day.
Don't get used to it.
Hey.
Be right there.
Who's that?
Hey.
Sounds cute.
Why don't you go ahead?
I'm gonna finish up here.
Nero's such a handy...
Nero's the actual handyman.
Not.
Oh, it's Kirie.
Wait, actually?
Is this her?
Oh.
Kirie, you've changed.
You've...
Your style.
This guy needs an inhaler.
Oh, this is how he loses his arm.
Nero, the food's getting clean.
Kirie, get back inside now!
Oh!
What?
He just stole it?
No way!
Back?
Oh my god!
Look at that stance.
I'm running out of time.
For real?
He just took his arm!
Nero bleeds out.
End of game.
All of this is just finna.
Oh, dream.
Trying not to get us killed on the way there.
He was taking it back.
Let's...
It's Virgil's sword!
Wait, I kind of miss having like a...
The full...
S...
D...
C...
A...
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
This game is filled with secrets and easter eggs at every corner and there's no...
Longer any time penalty, so you're free to explore.
Ah, okay, cool.
Nero got disarmed.
I like this time...
Oh, look!
It even shows who's together in the like the timeline.
That's it.
No more wheels from here.
All right.
Guess I'm walking then.
Yo, yo, yo.
Check it out.
And this is...
From Morrison.
I think it's...
I keep adjusting the audio just like before.
Oh, Morrison's letter.
It's been a good 30 years since I last wrote something like a letter.
Don't have a typewriter or nothing.
So, unfortunately, you're stuck with my shitty handwriting for now.
I heard you're heading back to Redgrave.
Wasn't sure exactly what I could do for you.
I'm not a powerhouse like you or the sharpest knife in the drawer.
Still giving my business.
The least I can do is get you a few leads.
Can't say exactly how useful they'll be to you, but hey, gotta be better than nothing, right?
I like this music.
So, the first time I met Dante, he actually went by a different name.
Tony...
Tony Redgrave.
Morrison was in the anime.
Ah, gotcha, gotcha.
Tony Redgrave.
Bet that got your attention, huh?
Tony Redgrave?
Redgrave City?
Just a coincidence?
Or something more?
I honestly can't say.
Still, figured if you're heading into that...
In that direction, you might be able to learn the truth yourself.
That's why I've decided to tell you everything about the Dante I know.
It ain't every day that I just give this stuff away, boy.
You best be grateful.
Morrison's letter.
The more missions you complete, the more information you'll be able to be like Morrison's letter.
Boy, we get all of Dante's secrets.
It's...
Hey, are we doing this or what?
Yes, this is a very serious alias.
I'm waiting on you.
I'm cooking.
Any special orders?
Oh, do we buy from her?
In this game?
What's with mint and robot armed guys?
I don't know!
Hey, I got a new arm for ya.
Sparta tools!
So cute!
I really worked out a sweat on that one!
Geburra?
Whoa!
Customize.
Here you can use Rorbs to acquire skills, replenish items, or change equipped gear to help you get a leg up in battle.
Durable.
Cycle through the tabs at the top of the screen to select a section to customize.
Uh, you can acquire skills and abilities.
Once you have acquired a skill or ability, you won't be able to reverse the...
I won't be able...
Oh, I like how they're just like, hey!
Um, remember how you used to be able to be like, I don't like this.
I'm gonna sell it.
Not this time.
No refunds here!
Won't be able to reverse the decision.
Select try to test them out before making a commitment!
Oh my god!
That's crazy!
Devil breakers.
Wow!
Buy in bulk.
Okay.
And our equipment.
Use edit to help find a setup that best fits your fighting style.
Okay.
The Florb is like...
This is an actual Megamind.
I don't think the Gorb should be called a Gorb.
It's a triangle.
It's not an orb.
Here you can buy orbs to increase.
Okay.
Whoa!
A speed!
Table Hopper.
Wire Snatch 2.
Air hike, my beloved.
Enemy Stip.
I didn't buy that before, but I kind of want to try it this time.
I'm sorry.
How much is that?
One.
Zero.
It's an armory!
Hold on.
Let me make sure I read the correct amount of zeros.
Zero.
A special taunt given only to those who paid a heavy price.
Increases stylish rank more than a normal taunt.
It better be like all the way to super stylish, sexy, stylin'.
Super sexy style beyond.
Pay to taunt!
That's crazy!
Oh my gosh!
It's worth all right.
Yeah.
Blue Rose, color up too.
Red Queen.
Wait, is this our...
This looks like our...
Wait.
What's...
I want to see what it...
Try it out in the void!
Whoa!
The void is a training ground offering free reign to try out skills and techniques.
Tweak specific settings in the menu to set up a training session just for you!
Wow.
Remember when 500 orbs was expensive?
Does this thing attack me?
Or are you just like gonna stand there?
Are you gonna do it?
Oh, he is just like a...
He's just a little guy.
He's a punching bag.
It feels so good.
Why am I turning around?
Why does it turn around?
Is it not locked on?
I guess so.
Okay.
Wow.
It's even showing what my movements are.
You guys can see.
That's crazy.
Wow.
You can see everything I'm doing.
Wait.
Guess what I'm gonna do.
Whoa.
How do I get out of here?
I went out of...
Does exit...
Oh, leave the void.
Okay, good.
Quit the void.
Yes, get me out of the void.
I think I'm gonna learn this one.
Yes.
There it is.
Streak two, baby.
Split.
Back Y.
Oh, mid-air.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Red queen combo.
We know many of these.
Or rather, like, we are familiar with many of these.
Is there an air hike there is?
I cannot afford it.
Color up deals a good amount of damage.
Hold on.
Let's see.
Exceed.
Oh, oh.
Devil breaker.
Devil breaker plus?
Oh, plus one magazine.
Okay.
I love that she's just chilling here.
But I kind of missed the music from the last game.
More arm slots.
Yeah, it sounds pretty...
It sounds like it could be worth it.
We still have 12,000, so...
Speed.
Yes, thank you.
Yeah, we definitely want speed.
I think I'll use...
Oh, and these two I can even try out.
I will definitely use a wire snatch too.
I want to get speed though.
Oh, just a little bit.
Viewers are reacting with excitement and amusement to a character named Mint jorking her sword in the game.
They are providing tips and suggestions for optimizing her moves and abilities.
Wow, speed!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Speed King.
Happy birthday!
Nice.
Wait, I wanna try.
How do you just mid-air press A near an enemy?
Wait, I wanna try it.
Why is this one so expensive?
I don't remember it being this pricey before.
Why is it so expensive now?
Oh.
Wait, where are you?
W-w-w-w-w, w-w-w-w-w-w-w-w-w.
Wait, come here.
Why can't you just keep jumping on him?
Wait.
Try taunting the air.
Right and hide.
Wait, hold on.
Let's get airborne.
Come on.
Wait.
Whoa.
Wait, hold on.
Come here, come here.
Oh, I keep forgetting to like, when you do this.
So
cute.
Bad night.
Come here.
Try to rev after the taunt.
Wait, rev?
Also...
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Um...
It's getting cool.
Wait.
Someone said to rev.
I see it.
I see it now.
It looks the same.
Let's get airborne.
Woo!
Shall we dance?
Taunt then rev.
Oh.
What'd you say?
Taunt then rev, rev, rev.
You can rev and taunt.
I can't?
What'd you say?
I'm confused!
Right now.
Wait.
Hold on.
Let's get airborne.
Like that?
Oh, it's...
It won.
Wow, it did it in one try.
Oh, I see.
I see.
Oh.
No, it didn't.
Wait.
It was taunt.
Wait, what was it?
Which...
What was the order?
Ah, there it is.
Ah, I did it.
I did it.
Okay, okay.
Uh...
Okay, hold on.
Oh, wait.
Ah, wait.
What's the timing?
It's timing perfectly.
Yeah, I gotta get it.
Hold on.
Am I too early?
What?
When he puts his feet on the sword.
Okay.
Let's get airborne.
I mean, it's tough.
Like always.
Ah!
I don't know what I'm doing wrong.
Oh, timing.
Okay.
It's something you'll get your...
Yeah, I'm just gonna...
Ah!
See, sometimes I get it so easily.
And sometimes I don't.
But I'll keep practicing it.
Oh!
We did it twice this time.
Let's get airborne.
Okay.
Ah!
Hi!
Hey, hey hey hey.
Side-sepping.
Go, go Nero!
Go, Nero!
Go!
That was handy, though.
Thank you for teaching that to me, you guys.
Get more orbs!
I want it.
Okay.
Let's see.
Maybe... Maybe I'll save up for... Wire Snatch 2.
Air Hike.
Okay.
Wait.
Oh, no.
I want to see the other stuff, too.
Devil Breakers.
Oh!
Oh, you got... Wait.
A mobile... Devil Breaker letting you cancel attacks with shockwaves or fire.
Converged...
Oh, wait.
Can I... Do I have enough for... Oh, I do have enough for this one.
We'll expand.
You can get up to eight!
Wow.
Hi, Dada!
Buy in bulk.
Purchase one of each Devil Breaker.
Currently available in the menu.
There's no discount for buying in bulk.
Okay.
Letting you cancel attacks.
I'll try it.
Just finish at the gym.
What's here?
What did this bring?
Some trivia.
Dante was in debt because he didn't charge people if they were poor and sends money to...
If... To... To... A late partner's daughter out of guilt.
Wee...
Oh, we have one in here.
Let's put that in there.
I guess we'll... Get to try it eventually.
Oh, God.
That thing is hideous.
It's so ugly.
That thing made...
I don't think I never... I didn't think that...
I didn't think that they really could make it any worse looking.
But, like, they just...
Oh, yeah.
I'm blurb shaming right now.
It's so bad.
Oh, my gosh.
Holy...
Okay.
Quick customization.
Yeah, I want to actually like...
We'll just get into the game.
We can always do more custom...
I'm guessing...
Yeah, you can customize after every mission.
There you go.
Customize screen is accessible from the mission menu.
Wait, so...
There's no...
So only the mission menu?
Blorb watched with...
Blorb goes bent up.
You'll see?
Oh, okay.
You have some mid-mission.
Okay.
Mission star...
Wait, why is it an exclamation point?
There's so many...
It's like so familiar and so different at the same time.
It's strange.
You know?
It's so strange.
There she is!
Oh.
Sorry, ma'am.
Shall we dance?
Taunt her?
I did.
What'd you say?
Wait, now?
Let's get in!
I'm too good!
Damn, they even stole the clothes off the mannequins.
I need to catch up to V.
Fast.
Okay.
Is that a person standing there or...
Oh, these are...
Oh, technically.
Technically, yes.
Oh, look at that shadow!
Oh my god, that's so awesome!
This is so messed up.
Ew!
Nice.
Give me...
Roars...
Oh, there's some more over here.
Okay.
You guys said to explore a little bit more.
I am exploring.
I'm exploring.
Oh, yeah!
I hate furniture!
Yeah!
We hate furniture!
Wait, what's up here?
Anything?
Smokin' sick...
Snack shack!
I like the decorations in this area.
It's very cute.
It's so trendy here.
Smokin' snake...
Wait.
Smokin' sick...
Snack...
Shack.
Oh!
I think I scared him off.
My bad.
Yeah!
We hate benches!
We hate any form of furniture!
Oh, gosh!
The people...
Ew!
What if you touch them?
It's so gross!
Coffee...
And donut!
Wait.
It's like an eyeball.
Look how cute it is!
But...
Breaking furniture doesn't seem to give you anything anymore.
And that's...
Pretty disappointing.
I'm not gonna lie.
Not gonna lie.
That makes me a little bit sad.
Hachiko?
Ah...
Miro, you monster!
What if you get the bad end just for doing that?
Wait.
Now I'm the evil creature.
Whoa, the atmosphere is so cool.
Oh,
stylish rank.
Savage.
Among other things, the length and variety of your combos determine how many stylish points you get.
Ooh, yeah, we know.
Oh, I'm here.
I'm here.
Wait.
Oh, I forgot to do it.
Ah, no, wait.
Ah, yeah!
Woo!
Come here.
Ah, dang it.
I almost had it.
Yeah.
Oh.
Rup, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
Riding high.
Oh, ah, yeah, yeah.
Ew.
Ooh, he's nasty.
You only get song lyrics on B and up.
Let's get air for it.
No way.
Riding high.
Let's get air for it.
Ah!
Okay, that took me a couple tries.
That took me a little bit.
Kind
of, how would you identify, like, a secret, you know?
Like, what would be, like, to look, be on the lookout for to find a...
Oh, yeah, my hands.
Thank you.
Yeah, yeah.
The B button.
Something's doing in a city like this.
Something to this place.
Hmm.
Something suspi...
Oh.
A hand.
Let's go.
How did she get over here?
Secret.
Yeah, I know you can rev after every hit.
I'm just...
Uh, I...
I...
Did not really get used to it in, um...
The first game.
So...
Or, like, in...
Uh...
Four.
So, I didn't really learn how to do it.
Can you actually defeat these things?
You can?
Playing DMC2?
Nice.
Get away!
Not making it easy for me, huh?
Oh, there's more.
I love the way he sidesteps.
Oh, there's more?
Oh!
Oh.
I wish I had that...
What's it called?
Come here!
Dude, where are you going?
What the hell are you?
Wait!
I can't hit you at all!
Out of the way!
Oh, I can't even lift you up!
Come here!
Wait...
I can't...
Ouch!
He's too fat!
He's got, like, mega rorbs, though.
Okay, I'm just going in circles, but...
Dummy thick man.
He's the roar bug.
I want my, like...
The one that you go in the air and then you go...
On the ground.
I want that one back.
I've never seen them fight back.
Oh, yeah.
Um, I was just showing you all the features of the game.
Okay, I'll keep going now.
Split!
Yeah!
Oh!
Oh my God!
Oh, dang it!
Holy cow!
Come on!
Oh my God!
Holy cow!
Get out of my gun!
Yippee!
I like how I grab them and then shoot them away.
Whoa!
Oh, yo!
She's feeling motivated.
Bang!
A little bit.
Let's go, baby!
Let's go!
Whoa!
Anything on top of the horse?
So close.
Come on, Nero.
Live your...
My little pony.
He's like, I'm a...
Pegasister.
Wait.
He would be brony.
So how do you...
Like, how easy is it to break the arms?
Because I haven't even broken a single one.
Stand down its head?
That's what I was trying to do.
Can you actually...
Stay on the horse?
I'm trying to actually get on it.
Wait.
I actually am trying to...
Oh!
See?
I knew.
I knew that there was something about the horse.
I knew my senses were tingling.
But yeah.
What was it?
Sorry.
What?
What was it about the arm?
Charge, attack, or LB bomb?
Oh, that's right!
You can LB!
I keep thinking that's...
You know...
Or...
Devil trigger, so...
Aw, these people were just trying to leave.
This guy looks so sad.
Oops, sorry.
I barely touched him.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
I barely touched him.
Come on, Nero.
Have a little bit of tact, please.
Don't worry about breaking them.
Wait, can I get up there?
Oh, oh.
So close.
You got this.
You got this, buddy.
Or you could use the stairs.
Let's do that.
Just trying to be a little extra over here.
Wow!
Oh my gosh.
Thank you so much for the 15th.
Thank you!
Woohoo!
Oh yeah!
Wait, I'm gonna try it.
Maybe it's a waste on this guy, though.
Maybe it's a waste on this guy.
Oh no!
It's a...
Oh look, it's this guy!
Oh, he's leaving!
No, come back!
He's like, wrong hotel!
Wait, hold on.
Let me try it.
I think I killed all of them, no?
Hold B?
Oh, wait.
What's LB then?
Ah, to throw it away.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
So hold.
Okay.
I keep wanting to destroy everything for rorbs.
But that's just not how the game works anymore.
That's just not how the game works anymore.
Things have changed!
Hold on.
Making sure there's no other...
Wait, is there a map?
I don't see one.
Devil may cry.
It's changed.
No map, okay.
Though it seems kinda linear, I'm not gonna lie.
It's not gonna be any place to explore.
At least in these, you know.
Who's talking?
Who's yelling?
Huh.
Looks like I'm gonna make it there before you do, V.
What do you mean?
V's right there.
Whoop!
Oh my god, he just let it happen.
Oh.
Trying to stop me.
Whatever shall I do?
I don't like that.
Examine.
Ew!
Oh!
Neathog hatchling!
A hatchling of the parasitic Neathog.
It feeds on weakened parts of the...
Clipfoth.
Destroying its internal structure.
Okay.
We got a little creature.
Oh, and I put him in here?
Ew!
Destroy him!
Parasite.
Clif...
Clifloff.
That'll be in case you're grabbed by an enemy.
Ah, okay, okay, okay.
The arm will explode and stun them.
It's like an oh shit button.
Ah, okay.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay.
I will remember.
Hopefully.
I'll try to at least.
Okay.
Wow, there's really...
It's like exploration, but also not really.
Orbs.
Oh, here?
He doesn't seem like a demon to me.
He's got a lot to say.
Nero.
Did Mito steal all of Nero's hair and add her hair?
I know, right?
I should make my hair shorter.
Nero got his little Jack Frost cut.
I don't know which one I like.
Usually I feel like I would prefer this cut, but I don't know what I...
But on him, I don't know.
Which...
Which way did I come from again?
Wait, you can't be lost.
Wait, the next objective.
Press and hold LS.
Wait, if you're lost your way...
What?
Wait, no way.
Wait, let's see.
Wait, I'm...
I'm going this way.
Oh!
Oh, I really...
It really does.
Okay.
Oh, I see.
I see.
Well, hold on.
I haven't lost my way just yet.
I...
I'm...
Oh.
Okay, I'm gonna hold B.
I think I messed it up.
Where is he going?
Wait, come back!
Hold on!
Wait, don't leave!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Hold on, hold on.
This is the way we're supposed to go.
What's upstairs?
Nothing.
Turn around.
See?
It pays.
It pays to explore.
Literally, it pays.
Look, we're already almost so close to air hike.
Oh, wait.
Let's check in here.
It pays!
Oh, come on.
There was a trap!
No!
Ah!
Don't come rushing at me like that!
You scared me!
Damn it.
Hold on.
Wait.
No.
Hold on.
There we go.
Oh, damn.
I was two busy times and he missed me.
Yeah!
Let's get out of my suck!
Let's get airborne.
Riding hot.
Very good.
Good job, Nuro.
Cup, cup, cup, cup.
I can't get over the way he moves.
It's too good.
All right.
Oh, we need another...
Oh, I still have the same one?
No.
Okay.
I gotta go find another.
Oh.
Let's check this room first.
Okay.
Wow.
This place, like...
Where did all the furniture go?
Like, it went to hell so fast.
I mean...
Like, it just feels like it was already empty.
Not that the furniture was, like, obliterated.
Mead hog.
Oh.
We gone!
Where are you?
Yeah!
I got a bluer fragment!
Where is he?
Wait, I can't see anything.
Oh, there we are.
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Thank you so much for the raid!
Hello, hello, hello.
Wahey!
Yo, we totally got that.
Let's go.
Oh, look.
We could've just run over...
Whatever.
Nice!
Hiya!
So, it might be worth practicing in the void.
Riding high!
Okay.
Let's get airborne!
Riding high!
Ugh!
I feel like I'm pressing it at the same time every time, but...
Clearly, I'm not.
Is there anything else in here?
Just the bluer fragment?
That was awesome, though, that we found that.
Very cool.
Riding high!
Raymack, thanks for the gifted!
Ducky, thanks for the gifted!
Thank you, guys.
Probably a three frame.
Maybe.
Let's get airborne!
Riding high!
And...
Turn to dust.
Work.
Nevermind.
Ew!
Wait, I think I'm...
There we go.
Actually, I knew I was doing it early on that one.
Wait, why did I do that when I know I'm gonna do that?
Ah!
I am getting the timing a bit better.
Actually.
Ah!
Rude!
So rude.
Okay.
Um...
Oh, here we go.
Oh!
Oh my gosh, you guys.
I learned something.
Okay, so...
Sometimes I don't play my games on my computer.
Sometimes I play them on, like, my TV.
And I learned that Paws is one of those cats that loves to, like...
She'll, like, look at everything that's happening on the TV.
And so, uh...
Last night, I put on cat TV for...
Like, I just Googled, like, TV for cats.
Or, like, you know, like, videos for cats.
And, like, it was one with a bunch of birds and stuff.
And she...
The whole...
She was, like, getting up...
I've never had a cat that would do this.
She was getting on the table.
She was getting on the TV stand.
She was, like...
Every bird.
Oh my god.
I was, like...
She's...
She's doing the cat thing!
It was so cute!
I've never had a cat that's done that before.
So I was, like...
This is so fun.
Bird, bird, bird.
And then she would, like, follow the birds with her eyes.
And I was like, oh my gosh.
Oh, we can just go around.
Whoa.
Someone's doing...
Oh, secret.
That's what a secret mission is.
As you progress through missions, you will come across special patterns scrawled on the parts of the environment.
What?
One of my previous cats, Bill, would watch NASCAR and bat at the cars.
Yeah.
Stand on the glowing point nearby and adjust your viewing angle to line up the pattern.
What?
That's so cool.
Secret missions present you with a challenge that...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, let's see.
Where's the glowing part?
Oh.
It's...
Oh, wait.
Oh.
Oh, here.
Secret mission.
What is it, though?
Wait.
Secret mission?
It said A, no?
Do I have to line it up even more?
Oh, there we go.
Eliminate all of the demons.
We could probably do this one, right?
It's an optical puzzle.
Those are so cool.
All we gotta do is kill them.
Oh, there's a time limit.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, shoot.
Hold on.
Okay.
Never mind.
I give up.
Oh, there's flying guys, even.
Come here.
Oh.
Woo.
I
pulled my devil trigger.
I don't think I...
Oh, I made it.
Second floor fragment.
I pulled my devil trigger.
Okay.
Cool.
Hold on.
I'm gonna...
Sorry.
If you don't like how I play, just go, please.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Um...
This way.
No?
Yes?
Oh, yes.
No?
Excuse me.
They're in my way.
Wait.
Oh?
Hold on.
This is the time.
I'm lost.
Last game.
This way.
Oh.
Oh, the door is open.
I couldn't tell.
Wow, this room is clean.
How did this room get spared?
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, dang it.
Hold on.
Ah.
I couldn't get it.
No.
Come
on.
Let me just kill one guy, please.
Thank you.
Oh.
There we go.
Savage.
We can't.
Oh, I just heard the lyrics though.
I feel like...
I need her to start singing sooner.
Hey guys, I'm too good at the game.
I need to get the S-Rag faster.
Hello.
Stupid tree, stupid tree, stupid tree.
Take out your aggression, Miro.
There's a lot down here.
Is that a...
Is that a health...
thingy?
Not the chair.
It is?
Okay.
That's what I thought.
Oh, where did you come from?
Did he die?
Oh my gosh.
I keep...
I keep trying to grab them.
I think I got him.
Oh, there's so many Rorbs everywhere.
Oh yeah.
Sometimes I try to do Buster and I forget that I'm locked on.
Or vice versa.
Or I do like it out of order.
Like I'll do...
I'll lock on...
I'll do this.
But I'm...
You know what I mean?
It's just, you know...
Miro, I...
Only had the chance to play with him for a whole game.
It's not like I would be totally used to him or anything by this point.
That's craziness.
I only got to play with him the whole time.
Okay, no.
Whatever.
Oh.
Nasty.
Give me the...
Oh, give me the creature.
Give me the creature.
I wish to see the baby.
Rorb nearby?
Where at?
Up here.
Climb the wall.
Um...
I hate to break it to you, but this is a city.
There's...
It's all wall.
Wall by the arm.
Okay.
Oh, that's sick.
Oh.
Hell...
End to Nora.
Cool.
These guys look awesome.
Woo!
Oh, gosh.
I'm trying to dodge.
Oh.
Can I dodge these guys?
If I...
Chill out.
Oh, gosh.
I'll challenge it.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Thank you.
The game was like, that's where you need to put the baby.
Thanks, game.
Okay.
So this wall...
Oh, I see it.
Oh, thank you, guys.
I will take that.
Thank you.
Yeah, you're right.
Oh.
This way.
I still don't understand...
With the...
With the flea.
Oh, man.
I'm getting sick of this.
Like...
Do I...
So I hold it.
And then do I, like, press it again to make it explode?
Or...
Is it a countdown?
Oh, you can shoot it.
You shoot it.
Ah.
I see.
Do I get hurt by my own explosion?
Oh, my God.
This is so sad.
Two of them?
No?
Okay.
Yippee.
This looks like...
This is, like, so Pompeii.
You know?
That's what it feels like.
Oh, that's a person.
Sorry.
Sad.
Oh, look.
Warbs.
Sad.
Oh, someone's calling.
Some telephones still have active phone lines.
Get closer and check it out.
Uh...
Moshi, Moshi.
Yeah?
I guess the phone still works.
Hello?
Took you long enough, dumbass.
What happened to the third recall?
Tell you what.
You call me now...
How'd she know I was here?
Oh.
Wait.
Is this how we...
Buy from her mid-game?
Wait.
She comes?
If I call her?
Wait, that's so awesome.
Calling Niko.
You can call Niko's trailer where you can trade red orbs for skills and items.
Any telephone you find is a chance to call Niko.
What?
Uh, let me in.
This is so cute.
Wait.
Customize.
Oh.
You just here to window shop?
All right.
We have just enough for air hike.
What do I get that or wire snatch too?
The music is such a vibe.
Air hike.
I think you guys are right.
Eddie.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Air hike is pretty handy.
I'm broke.
Okay.
Bye.
This is so cute.
The way you can just...
Wait, hold on.
I like this.
Hold on.
Where do I go?
Wow.
It looks like...
It looks like four here.
Like the environment.
Very cool.
All right.
Who's going to ambush me here?
My first boss?
Already?
Oh my gosh.
Our Uber.
Somebody call a doctor?
You limp.
I wasn't expecting any survivors.
Big boy.
Sorry to disappoint you.
Hey.
You happen to see a guy around here?
About this big.
Used as a cane?
I was supposed to meet him.
Did you snack on him?
Snack?
I'm your blood.
It's a very precious sacrifice.
Oh my god.
He's so cool looking.
You know it do me no good.
I must have every last trouble.
To rule the underworld.
As king.
He's got a lot of eyeballs.
I don't know.
I mean, you're a big guy and all, but you seem more like a knuckle scrapping fart in the wind than anything else.
Nero has learned so much from Dante.
You know who I am?
How do you keep any food down?
Whoa.
Oh.
He's chomping on them rocks.
He's getting all those minerals.
What?
Do you do parties?
Oh my god.
Oh no.
Okay, here we go.
Boss battle.
Let's go.
Whoop.
Yeah, maybe I will.
Sorry, I'm about to go.
Oh gosh, I wish I could have dodged that.
Okay.
Whoop.
Oh shoot.
Ah.
Whoop.
Uh-oh.
Oh my god.
No, no, no.
Holy cow.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna lose my first fight.
Let's get here.
Oh my...
Oops, that's not what I meant to do.
Ah!
Holy shit.
I'm gonna die in this guy.
Wait.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
First death of the game.
Here it comes.
Woo!
Wait, can I just have him like collapse the ceiling on himself?
Oh,
oh.
Run Nero, run.
Oh my god.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
We're back in business, baby.
Did you just call me?
Would you just call me?
Ouch, ouch.
Ouch.
Oh wait.
Oh shoot.
Please.
Ah!
Holy shit.
Um.
Hold on.
Uh.
No, I'm gonna die.
I wish I had a star.
Oh, they gave me just...
Just a little tiny bit of Gorb.
Gorb and that's a hit.
Ah!
Oh gosh, I'm dead.
Ah.
I don't even...
I don't think I have this...
I could use Rorbs to revive?
Ah.
What?
You were doing well, though.
Thanks.
I have a Gorb?
When did I use... Oh, I do have one.
Give up is better.
Why?
It's not worth it.
It costs more every time.
Ah, okay, okay.
Yeah, I don't want to revive here then.
I don't want to... I don't want it to go up on the first battle.
That would suck.
Oh my god.
The last judgment draweth nigh.
Okay, checkpoint.
Ha.
Wait, so how much does it cost?
How much does it cost to have it?
Good first try.
I feel like we got pretty... we got pretty far.
Oh, I'm gonna skip it.
Sorry.
Yeah, maybe I will.
Sorry, I'm about to kill you.
Oh, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh my gosh.
I try to dodge and I instead...
Um...
I instead, uh...
Jump.
I guess I'm not holding the right stuff around.
WAH!
Alright, he's already starting to do this.
WEEE!
It's your grain.
Jack it up all you want.
You can at least get in little...
...damage.
I Uranus' champion.
Ding it.
I at least missed it.
At least I did.
OUGH!
UH!
I CAN'T GET OUT!
NO, THIS SUCKS!
NO, PLEASE LET ME OUT!
WHERE AM I?
Oh, I don't know...
Oh...
That sucked!
Uh...
Go...
Oh, there he is.
He's just chillin' there.
Ah!
Oh, come on.
Oh, there's another grower!
I see it.
Oh, please.
Ouch.
Ah, please.
Wait, how do I use the...
Wait.
How do I change to a different one?
Or do I only have burrow left?
Hold me to change it.
Or charge it.
You're eating garbage now?
Oh, he's eating the garbage.
Oh.
Okay, go, go, go, go.
I only have one left.
What?
I wasted all of them?
Oh, God!
Holy shit.
Ouch.
Oh, dang it.
I wasn't close enough.
No!
Oh!
Ouch!
Wait, it unlocked another dorm.
Take it.
Oh, my God.
Ouch!
No, please, please!
Please do any damage!
What?
Come on out!
This doesn't mere damage.
How about we wrap this Seppin?
Oh!
Choppa, Choppa, Choppa, Choppa!
Haa haa
Just keep dodging, Diro!
Just keep dodging!
No, no, no, no!
No, no!
No, no, no.
Just keep dodging.
Just keep...
No, no, no, no, no!
Please grab that.
I got it.
No!
I was so close!
I'm so tempted.
Thank you, Doomguy!
Waste the Rorbs.
How much does it cost?
All of them?
Wait, let's see.
What does it mean?
Revive with three bars.
What?
Wait, next is 7,500.
Oh, hell no.
Wait.
This is insane.
1,500 to 7,500.
7,500 is insane.
Wait, they reset every mission?
Is that true?
Wait, is that true?
First use trial.
I'm seeing yes and no.
So I can't tell.
Mixed messages.
I don't know.
I can hear him yelling in the background.
Ah!
Well, let's try one more time.
Let's try one more time.
I think we can get him.
We were so close this time.
As long as I don't get sucked, I think I'll be good.
If I don't get sucked, then I think I'll be good.
Oh, wait.
Well, we kept our Rorbs.
Is there anything we can buy?
Uh, ma'am?
Is there anything... We can pay for?
Let's see.
She does have a blue Rorbs I can buy.
Oh, I only have one arm left?
Oops, you're so right.
I think I'm gonna buy the Overture arm, though.
Because I think this one...
Oh, wait.
It did also...
Oh.
Try charged...
Burrow.
What's the hold B, right?
It's good for schmoven, is it?
This game is made to be played in multiple ways.
Yeah, yeah, just if you...
Yeah, if you, like, suggest something and I don't take your suggestion, it's not that I...
You know, everybody has different play styles, so...
I always go with what feels most comfortable for me.
Yeah, yeah.
Um...
Wait, hold on.
There's some more over here.
Yeah, no, I just hate you specifically, so true.
Wait, did I miss...
Oh, no, there it is.
Yeah, if I don't listen to you, I specifically hate you in particular.
Why is this glowing?
She hates me.
There's no such thing as Cooper's hair.
I knew it.
I don't know what to do.
I don't think I can buy any sort of abilities.
I'm broke.
I'm so broke.
I'm so broke, yeah.
But that's okay.
Yeah, I'm broke.
Do they not have devil stars in this game or anything?
Sorry for a bit much.
We're just meaning to let you know all your options.
No, no, that's okay.
Okay.
Thank you.
Yeah, that's why I kind of want to say, you know, I might not follow what you say, but I appreciate when people, you know, try to help out.
I get it.
No items.
Wait, so I think this is what the arm is kind of confusing me.
So maybe I will just.
I'm going to buy.
Okay, I'm going to buy two.
Yes.
Good choice.
No more holy water.
Okay.
Now we put you in here, right?
And then if I buy.
You know,
I can find.
Wait.
Oh, I don't have enough money.
I'm stupid.
Oh, well, I guess that's it for us.
Let's go try.
Loving way three.
Thank you.
Only swap on breaking.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
I bought it.
I did.
I thought I had, I would have enough.
That's why I was so confused.
Okay.
I was like, what?
I thought I did the math.
Oh.
Cool.
Yes.
Here we go.
This will be a...
I'll train with it later.
But it'll be our last resort.
Okay.
All right.
Alrighty.
Now we're good to go.
G to G.
Ho.
All right.
What?
What up?
Ouch.
Get him in the butt.
Oh, I took damage on that.
That sucked.
Okay.
Not as strong as a start as before, but...
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
It's gonna start sucking.
Oh, man.
Okay, we can leave.
Tommy!
Get us, Tommy!
Oh, my God.
Oh, ho, ho, ho, ho.
Okay, but nothing to do so much...
So much to us.
Ouch.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
I know there's a...
Oh, sorry.
I kept doing...
Oh, my gosh.
I'm so stupid.
Slice, slice, slice!
Okay.
I got that one.
Nice.
Oh, he's about to start sucking.
Oh, wait.
Now he's on!
Oh, my God.
I thought he was about to start sucking.
Never mind.
Wait, now he's gonna start sucking?
When are you sucking?
When are we sucking?
I don't know.
Oh, now he's sucking?
Oh no, no, no, no, no.
You asshole.
Let's sleep?
Nevermind.
We're not leaving.
Oh my gosh.
Run, run, run, run, run.
Find, find Grorb.
Find Grorb.
Grorb!
Did I just parry that?
You're eating garbage now?
Yeah!
Oh my god, the parry!
I totally meant to do that.
Obviously.
I totally... I knew that was happening and I did that.
Oh my god.
That made my love so high.
And me, so low.
Edgar Allan Poe.
The raven.
Oh!
The panther.
Stevie, thank you!
Lasagna.
Lasagna!
Hey!
Ew!
Hey, don't take my rorbs from me, mister.
Thought I was gonna have to pick you out of his, uh...
Tummy teeth.
Tummy teeth!
Hahaha!
I was catching up on some reading.
Yeah.
Looks like a real page turner.
Is that where he got his name from?
V?
Yeah, he stole my kill!
Whoa!
So, uh...
You think Dante's still in there?
If Fiora's indefeated him, then...
I expect he's not much more than...
Clyphod pollen by now.
A what?
Clyphod.
It's a tree that grows in the underworld.
It thrives on human blood and...
Those whose blood it sucks, well...
Let's just say they don't turn out too well.
Oh, that's what happens.
Well, in any case, we need to find out.
If Dante's alive, we'll save him.
If not, we don't.
He's alive!
First, we...
Need to exterminate some...
Clyphod roots.
Clyph...
Clyphoth?
Is that how you say it?
Clyph...
B!
What the hell are you?
I know, I know, I'm late.
Shut it!
The road's all clogged!
Hey, you must be B, huh?
Hey, you gonna get that?
Ding, ding, ding, right by your feet!
Oh, what is that?
Oh!
New weapon!
Hoo-ee!
I'm gonna make something amazing out of this...
Oh, her nails are so cute!
She's so cute!
Did you just sniff that?
Do you have any idea where that's been?
...up your butt.
Focus on the mission.
Yay!
Oh, it does give us more points.
I see it.
13.
What a woman.
Wow, we got a lot of warps from that.
Let's go.
6.26 AM.
Niko is literally... What do you mean, me?
I think we should split into two groups.
And cover more ground.
Good idea.
How?
Behold, my genius.
Oh my god.
Cash first.
Why does it gotta be red?
All the materials I collected for your little pet projects don't count for anything.
My brilliant badass work is worth every dime.
You know it.
Well, your quality control sucks ass.
And you know that.
Or maybe don't let the demon smack you around so much.
Ooh.
She's calling me.
She's saying...
I am truly gifted.
She's saying skill issue.
Bird's about to become lunch.
My grandmother was called the .45 caliber virtuoso, legendary gunsmith.
I hope to be like her someday.
An artist and a lethal artisan.
Oh my god, grandma!
Creator's art.
Whether it's a gun or a steel pot to cook.
Oh, yeah.
Any more questions?
Huh?
Little cheeky.
I'll take my leave now.
Everybody hates that she smokes in her car.
And if I don't see you along the way.
I'll see you at the bottom of the Klyphod.
Klyphod.
Sure.
What are you gonna do?
Can't say that word very well.
I gotta shake the cobwebs out.
I'll let you know.
Hey, you got any more questions?
Better ask it now.
I can't read minds.
What are the purposes of the buttons on her collar?
Whoa, Malfuji.
Malfuji.
Klyphod.
Yeah, yeah.
She can't...
She can't read minds yet.
Wow, we're only on mission three?
Crazy.
It's called fashion.
Yeah, I knew that.
Hey, hey.
I got a new arm for ya.
Oh, yeah.
Punchline!
Helter Skelter!
Wait, we got two new arms?
Makes up for a lack of range with superior piercing power.
Use it to break through enemy go...
Whoa!
Oh, golly.
I'm gonna have to be like...
I'm gonna have to like...
Learn when to...
Oh, my gosh.
So, I can already see.
You have to like set up your...
Your arms in a way that like...
Okay, I just used...
I just used Overture.
Now I break it.
And then I use Helter Skelter against this thing.
And I break it.
And then...
Oh!
Loadouts!
Yeah!
Oh, my God.
Interesting.
But how are you supposed to know what kind of enemies are in a run?
Punchline.
This Devil Breaker runs rampant, offering powerful strikes and flying rocket punches.
You can even mount it to move around.
That's the neat part.
You don't...
People love punchline.
Yeah, it seems to be the case.
Wait.
Did she give me any for free?
Yippee!
Wait, so I can...
Let's try it out.
Powerful strikes and flying rocket punches.
I see.
We'll put...
We'll put you here.
And you here.
If I go into the void and I use all these...
Well...
They don't...
Yeah, they don't...
Like...
It's not using them.
Let's see.
Hold on.
Now, I can get wire snatched too.
Void protects.
Okay.
They don't get wire snatched.
What's up?
Oh, wait.
Uh, let me try.
Okay.
Wait.
Oh, I was...
I was locked on.
That's why.
Hold B when it comes back?
Okay.
What?
Ah!
Uh-oh.
Uh.
Come on, baby!
Oh, I lost it.
Oops.
There it goes.
Okay, hold on.
So this one just...
This one...
There we go.
And then...
Okay.
You can attack while riding it too.
Oh, Gerbera.
This guy is so...
He was just lying there.
Like, do I have to get off?
Got a little something for you.
Oh, and I can move with it too.
Whoa!
Are you okay?
You can aim the beam?
Yeah!
I only realized that, like, at the very end.
Give me more!
Wait, let's save the board.
Let's do it again.
Haha.
Wow.
This needs ibuprofen.
Let's take ibuprofen together.
Okay.
Those are neat.
I like them.
Oh, there is a reset?
Oh, I didn't even notice.
The punchline is crazy.
Okay, hold on.
Oh.
Oh, you, you.
Oh, my God.
It went back for more!
Oh!
Wait, I'm just like...
Oh?
Hold me.
I can't... Wait, this feels... This feels so broken.
No?
This is how you're supposed to use it?
Oh my god!
Oh, it does low damage.
Okay.
Oh yeah, you're right.
You're right.
This is just one way to use it.
That's a way to use it, alright.
3, 4, 5, 6, 11... Oh, okay.
It takes quite a long time, actually.
I
know you can shoot it to make it go faster.
I just wanted to see how long it takes.
Yeah, that's why you shoot it.
That's why you shoot it.
Okay.
Very nice.
Actually, I want to just try using this.
Oh my god.
Wow!
Oh!
That's fun.
Oh my god.
Overture arm is created using part of Blitz.
Oh no!
Not Blitz!
Oh my god.
Not Blitz, please!
Jeez!
That thing was hellish.
I'm glad I only had to fight it like two times.
Okay, someone said to try... Wait.
Woah!
Oh!
It was still in the air!
Huh.
You okay?
While on the ground, just... Wait, was it?
Just before an attack hits.
Oh, this is the...
The dodge.
I didn't realize what was happening.
How am I supposed to... How am I supposed to try it though?
Is that it?
This just feels like a dodge, no?
Oh, you gotta change the settings.
Well, I'm not gonna buy it anyway.
Very cool.
Very cool!
Guys...
I know I'm only on mission three.
But I might actually call it today.
Um...
I...
Uh...
I got some new medicine.
And...
It's known for making you...
Uh...
Lightheaded.
And...
Dizzy.
So...
Um...
Next couple of streams might be a little...
Uh...
Shorter while I get used to it.
Um...
So, I apologize.
I'm sorry.
Um...
But...
So far...
I...
Like this game a lot.
But...
It kind of sucks that it just fell...
In that time when I started the new medicine.
So, I'm sorry.
Um...
But yay!
So...
Thanks for the streamers.
I feel better.
Next time...
I'll do double...
Times.
Since I...
Maybe I'll...
Maybe I'll switch it from like...
From Friday to...
Sunday or something.
But...
Um...
Yes.
I would like to go...
I would like to go longer...
Next time.
So that we can...
Get through...
Some more stuff.
Instead.
Mission 2 is one of the longer ones.
Because you're trying to figure these things out.
Yeah!
It felt...
I felt like I did more than...
More...
I was like...
Oh, wait.
We're only on mission 3 at the end of it.
So...
But that was okay.
Yeah.
So thank you guys.
I'm sorry that...
Um...
That...
Uh...
That is a bit shorter today.
But...
Um...
We're learning.
It's good stuff.
Why would you ever apologize for taking care of my I- Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah...
That's what I hear coming from you.
Wah, bah, bah.
Wah, bah, bah, bah.
Tutorials are draining.
We'll continue.
Well, um, before I... next time, too, I'll, like, uh... I'll go into the void and I'll, like, practice stuff.
I like the void because it gives me a chance to be, like, before I get into the game to remember how to do everything.
So, yeah!
Thank you, guys.
I hope you guys have a great weekend if I don't see you.
And if I see you, then awesome.
Um, but yeah, have a... have a good day.
Have a good night.
And, um, don't forget to watch W3.
I like the void.
Panic!
Thank you for the vibe I'm gifted!
Thanks, Chuna.
Awesome, though!
Thank you, everybody!
Yeah!
Double big cry five!
Actually, I'm so glad that I went into it so quickly after four.
Because I don't feel like I...
I feel more comfortable with the controls than I probably would have if I had waited a little bit longer, so.
Um, but yeah!
Thank you, guys!
And I'll see you next time!
Bye-bye!